[Applause]  tonight from the strike  three for three pardon me two for three  mark he's taken  one mid-range jumper here in this  quarter  one he is making  33 of his jump shots  in the series so far which is just  slightly lower than the 36 that he's  made  during the playoffs  two-time mvp  see i i think this this takes so long  like his routine and why interestingly  watching in pregame  he doesn't do it consistently sometimes  it's five dribbles sometimes it's six  there's the brooklyn crowd  counting out the second i don't think he  was the hold up that time  official courtney kirkland appeared to  be waiting for something i'm not sure it  was giannis